hallo leute hier sieht eure mal wanne
und willkommen zu einem etwas anderem
video auf diesem kanal und zwar möchte
ich oder ich habe sehr den drang dazu
euch eine sache mitzuteilen ich hasse
instagram die meisten wundern sich jetzt
wahrscheinlich warum ich das euch
erzählen
es hat für mich eine große bedeutung
weil mir heute etwas klar geworden ist
und zwar bei einem schluck kaffee let it
snow
ich glaube es schon hat diese woche noch
also passt die taste noch ich habe sie
zur weihnachtszeit gekauft okay das ist
gar nicht thema also es geht darum dass
wir heute etwas klar geworden ist und
zwar dass ich seit monaten eigentlich
auf instagram eine lüge leben
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen
dramatischer als es wahrscheinlich ist
für mich ist es aber sehr dramatisch
beziehungsweise war die erkenntnis heute
sehr dramatisch und ich bin zu dem
entschluss gekommen dass ich instagram
erstmal nicht mehr bespielen möchte also
keine fotos jetzt wirklich hochladen
will und die app auch erstmal glaube ich
von meinem handy löschen wertet main
kanal also diesen instagram account
werde ich wahrscheinlich nicht löschen
weil kann sich natürlich auch wieder
ändern das kann ja alles
man verändert sich aber momentan merke
ich ist dass ich diese app einfach nicht
brauche wie ist es dazu gekommen dass
ich eine lüge auf instagram lebe ich
weiß es gar nicht so genau wann es
angefangen hat ich kann ja mal nebenbei
so schauen ich glaube es hat so von
einem jahr angriff
ja das muss ja schon ein bisschen länger
aber so ungefähr seit einem jahr
versuche ich diese app so zu bespielen
dass ich einen schönen instagram account
habe beziehungsweise dass ich eine
schöne gute person bin
gleichzeitig habe ich immer wieder
versucht den leuten mitzuteilen haye
bleibt real es ist nicht alles gold was
glänzt unsere leben sind auch normal und
andererseits habe ich halt genau das
gegenteil gemacht ich hab halt nur die
schönsten seiten von mir gezeigt ich
habe angefangen fotos zu machen nur für
instagram was okay ist wenn du einen
instagram abis oder wenn du das gerne
macht und dich gerne präsentiert und
gerne tolle fotos von die hart für mich
war es allerdings so eine sache die ich
machen musste ich dachte ich machen muss
sie machen ich dachte das gehört einfach
zu deinem job dazu wenn du youtuber bist
und gerne videos produziert das du
natürlich auch einen instagram account
brauchst der ja dem die leuten folgen
damit du den einfach irgendwie im kopf
bleibt ist klingt alles so ein bisschen
wird aber ja das war einfach so mein
gedanke dazu und das habe ich dann
einfach gelebt und ich habe schöne fotos
von mir hoch geladen und dann irgendwann
fing es an dass ich halt extra oft fotos
von mir machen lassen oder selber
gemacht habe einfach nur damit ich etwas
posten kann und nicht weil ich etwas
posten möchte sondern einfach damit da
was kommt damit ich auf dem foto gut
aussehe und dass die leute denken dass
ich gut aussehend bin oder so ich bin
mir nicht sicher was überhaupt in meinem
kopf vorging
ich weiß nur dass es ein riesendruck
plötzlich wurde
fotos zu posten und die die jetzt sich
nicht groß mit insgesamt beschäftigen
die werden das jetzt auch ein bisschen
lächerlich finden das auch in ordnung
ich finde mittlerweile ist selber sehr
lächerlich aber es war für mich ein
großes problem und wenn jetzt jemand
draußen glaubt dass so was kein problem
sein kann dann können jetzt auch gerne
abschalten oder dran bleiben und euch
eines besseren belehren lassen
ich habe einfach angefangen nicht mehr
ich selbst zu sein und mir nebenbei
einen druck zu machen den ich furchtbar
fand und der mir aber nicht so richtig
bewusst war ich habe das gemacht und
wenn ich mit leuten über instagram
gesprochen habe dann ging es aber
meistens mit diesen satz einher naja ich
muss es ja machen es ja wie die
steuererklärung und sorry wenn du etwas
machst was für dich wie eine
steuerklärung ist die du glücklich
machen musste weil sonst ist ganz
schnell oben dann solltest du überlegen
ob du das wirklich noch tun willst und
ich habe darüber nie nachgedacht ob ich
das wirklich tun wir bzw wusste ich dass
ich das nicht gerne mache aber ich hab's
gemacht und dann dieses jahr habe ich
angefangen jeden tag ein bild zu posten
und dann hat sich so gesteigert dass ich
jeden tag mehrere bilder gepostet habe
dann hat er sich dazu gesteigert dass
ich dass ich immer so rein haben wollte
die zueinander gepasst haben
und da ist glaube ich bei mir dann alles
zugegangen da habe ich die krone der
scheinheiligkeit erreicht indem ich halt
scheiße gepostet habe dienten sind ja
schöne bilder
das sag ich ja gar nicht ist sind das
sind nette bilder
ich sehe darauf darauf hübsch aus ich
finde das sind coole bilder zum teil
aber warum ich halte persönlich nichts
von dieser ganzen instagram welt weil
für mich ist dass ich habe letztens eine
doku gesehen von wild kollektiv ist so
heißen die da haben sie influenza
während der fashion week in berlin
begleitet und das hat auch oft die
moderne litfaßsäule
das haben sie gesagt hier treffen sich
die modernen mit litfaßsäulen oder die
heutzutage gegen litfaßsäulen und genau
zu so einer litfaßsäule bin ich geworden
und ich habe es gehasst ich hasse es ich
finde wie gesagt meine meinung dürft ihr
anders sehen ich finde dass instagram
leben dieses ständige ich bin im urlaub
posting diese malediven bilder von denen
man schon so viele gesehen hat wenn man
pines ag und folgt die halt mal auf die
malediven uns eingeladen wenn ich könnte
mittlerweile im strahl kotzen wenn ich
nur noch einmal sehe dass jemand gerade
im flieger sitzt so nirgendwohin fliegt
also wenn man auf instagram unterwegs
ist hat man das gefühl dass heute nur
noch jeder mit dem flugzeug unterwegs
ist keiner wird mehr auto oder bahn oder
sonst was
nein alle fliegen und alle fliegen immer
zu den tollsten orten haben die
schönsten leben und das ist für mich
einfach ein ganz schlimmer oder eine
ganz schlimme perverse entwicklung die
wir so mit social media gemacht haben
als beispiel twitter bin ich fein mit
ich liebe twitter ich könnte auf twitter
viel zeit verbringen weil ich aber auch
die postings kreativer finde wenn leute
halt coole witze oder irgendwelche
gedanken diesem tag hatten posten
die sind meistens so dass sie mich zum
schmunzeln oder so zum nachdenken
bringen anders als auf instagram wo man
halt einfach nur schöne menschen sieht
und nach dem fünften schönen safety ist
dann auch gut irgendwann aber nie man
sollte dieses sieht diese plattform wenn
ich darüber nachdenke dass ich morgens
aufwache und erstmal auf insta story
gucke was die leute so machen warum
warum interessiert es mich was gerade
rapper xy oder beauty bloggerin
blablabla so gemacht haben
es sind auch was nur noch gefühlt fast
nur noch werbe postings da also jeder
zweite in story ist und dankeschön an
diese firma dankeschön dieses immer
danke an diese firma es ist keine
werbung aber ich hab's geschickt
bekommen und ich habe auch angefangen
sachen geschickt zu kriegen und fand das
toll und dadurch dass ich jetzt
instagram enden werde nicht mehr
bespielen werde wird es auch aufhören
ich werde nicht mehr eingeladen ich weiß
nichts mehr bekommen weil die leute halt
nicht mehr davon ausgehen können dass
ich das post- und danke sagen dass zum
beispiel bei eschweiler sprich mal sehr
froh dass ich es bekommen habe weil ich
aber auch live in diesem herzen zu porte
und latsch super finde aber ich habe zum
beispiel letztens schuhe bekommt von new
balance kann ich euch mal zeigen
dankeschön an new balance die balance
mit so einer box mit dem spiegel drin
super schön und ich habe diese schuhe
bekommen ich habe sie einmal an gehabt
und habe die ganze zeit noch diese box
behalten weil ich dachte ja gut ich muss
ja aber auch irgendwie noch auf
instagram posten
und dann habe ich bei shanti gesehen
dass sie die gleichen schule geschickt
hat und da hat sie halt zum kurzen
bumerang darüber gemacht und danach
wieso ich muss auch posten
und es ist ein druck der am tag da ist
denn nicht so wirklich spürt so es ist
jetzt nicht so dass mich das ganze
erfolgt aber unterbewusst unterbewusst
weist die ganze zeit ich muss irgendwie
posten so ich dachte diese box diese box
liegt da hinten im flur ich dachte ich
noch nicht wegschmeißen ich muss
eigentlich was posten damit damit ich
danke sagen weil ich die zugeschickt
gekriegt habe weil ich halt eine moderne
mit litfaßsäule geworden bin
die durch produkte zeit wird ist es cool
für die ersten mal etwas geschenkt zu
kriegen aber nach dem 30 make up kisten
box die man bekommt hat man dann auch
irgendwann einfach genug kam und ich bin
eigentlich nicht der typ der gerne viel
kram hat und das macht mich so war ich
instagram
ja und dann habe ich angefangen jeden
tag bilder zu posten und wurde halt
wirklich zu der falschen person für mich
die ich sein konnte und das hat dann
plötzlich aufgehört
also ich habe einfach nicht mehr
gekostet das war am ersten märz bild
gepostet und dann habe ich seitdem immer
wieder darüber nachgedacht
seitdem habe ich ein neues tattoo einen
kleinen berliner spatzen und da war es
auch die nummer dass ich das tattoo
bekommen habe und das gefühl hat ich
muss es ja posten
ich habe ein neues tattoo also muss das
ins gramm auch erfahren weil die leute
die folgen und alle anderen die schaffen
das die posten ohne ende die familien
kriegs einfach alles mit
dann hat sich vor paar tagen meine
haarfarbe geändert
und da habe ich wieder gedacht ich muss
das posten des kann ja nicht sein dass
ich von dieser farbe seit drei tagen
habe und das internet noch nicht
bescheid weiß
wie krank ist das bitte ich möchte doch
mein leben leben
ich hab hier vogel häuser gebastelt mit
meiner freundin da sieht man dass wir
einfach aus spaß haben wir uns
vogelhäuschen gekauft und sie beklebt
und während wir diese vogelhäuschen
gemacht haben dachte ich muss der posten
weil es ist ja witzig es ist ja cool aus
wahrheit moment der götter meiner
freundin und mia und nicht im internet
ich habe euch alle super gerne ich weiß
da draußen die mir zu schauen sind so
viele coole leute wenn ich auf der
straße treffe und ihm ich anspreche habe
ich immer wieder diesen gedanken geil du
schaust meine videos das finde ich mega
cool ich weiß dass da draußen richtig
coole leute sind und ich kann sagen dass
ich euch echt gerne aber auch dafür dass
ihr mich sehr gut support in dem ihr
meine videos schaut aber dieser moment
gehört meiner freundin mia und alleine
dass ich darüber nachgedacht habe es zu
posten hat mir irgendwie auch so ein
bisschen die magie weggenommen
ich hab's nicht gemacht was gut war weil
wenn ich es gemacht hätte dann weil sie
nicht mehr es halt wer halt dieses
schöne vogelhäuschen machen wer zu einer
in story geworden
es klingt alles komisch und fühlen die
leute dies auch gerne posten und da sehr
aktiv sind die werden jetzt sagen ja
aber man kann es
weil eben posten so das ist ja ok aber
für mich ist es das nicht mehr
und ja heute kam der tag der tage und
ich bin sehr froh dass dieser tag kam an
dem ich einfach gemerkt ob instagram ist
nicht meine plattform diese welt diese
instagram welt ist absolut nicht meine
welt ich hasse es
ich hasse es dass leute mittlerweile nur
durch schöne fotos von ihnen also wisst
ihr menschen können auch mehr als schön
aussehen und modelt sie das
hauptberuflich machen und gut in ihrem
job sind die sind auch immer noch toll
und ich mag auch immer noch tolle models
bilder sehen wo es designer gibt die
sich da gedanken gemacht wurden
fotografen gibt er sich gedanken dazu
gemacht hat aber dieses diese masse an
bildern die wir jetzt mittlerweile in
unseren insta stories sehen und jeder
ist schöner als der andere
wie komisch ist es denn dass man zu
instagram immer gleichzeitig sagt ja
aber denkt immer daran diese leute haben
auch ein nicht so schönes leben also
diese leute können auch mal traurig sein
bei denen es auch nicht jedes frühstück
perfekt alleine dass wir uns dass
heutzutage so sagen müssen und immer
wieder klar machen müssen
die ist aber auch nicht jede woche auf
den malediven und die hat auch instagram
hat sie zwar ein perfektes leben aber
sie hat mich wirklich perfektes leben
kein perfektes leben
ich will aufhören mir darüber gedanken
zu machen ob jemand anderes ein
perfektes leben hat als ich oder so
andere leben anschauen und mir denken oh
mein gott
aber ihr ist alles super und dann immer
gleichzeitig denken nein bei ihr ist
nicht alles super da läuft auch nicht
alles so wie geleckt vielleicht schon
man weiß es nicht ich weiß was bei mir
nicht immer alles läuft wie geleckt und
ich und das verunsichert mich wenn ich
immer nur diese perfektion sehe und es
gibt natürlich auch tolle bewegungen wo
die frauen und sagen hey ich hier auch
cellulite und so aber das sind dann
immer so kleine moment
wo die leute sagen mir auch nicht
perfekt aber in sonst haben sie halt
immer nur perfekte postings und ja ich
habe dieses video heute spontan reden
wollen und trotzdem habe ich mich
geschminkt weil ich gerne geschminkt bin
es fühlt sich für mich aber trotzdem
anders an mit euch zu reden ich meine
meinung zu sagen
mit euch vielleicht bei dem einen oder
anderen gedanken auszulösen der
vielleicht so nicht gekommen wäre
als mich zu schminken hilfs machen für
ein foto für einmal cool an der wand
stehen für einmal süß mit einem
kaffeebecher irgendwie nen kaffee
posieren und sagen ich wünsche euch
einen tollen montag
was bringt mir das du mir ein tollen
montag würde ich also es bringt euch
doch gar nicht alle hengste wenn man da
draußen wie das trotzdem gerne machen
und macht es weiter ich jeder jeder mag
ich meinen kram ich mag auch nicht ein
gramm
und dann habe ich noch so weiter gedacht
warum warum dachte ich überhaupt das
instagram meiner karriere hilft ich
denke nämlich dass ich jetzt nicht so
ein person hype habe also ich glaube
nicht dass ihr meine videos schaut weil
ihr mich so absolut faszinierend findet
ich glaube viele meiner videos werden
einfach geschaut weil das thema
interessant ist weil ihr wissen wollt
wie irgendwas schmeckt oder weil ihr
wissen wollt wie nagel dinger
funktionieren vielleicht aus meinem
tagebuch das ist so ein persönliches
format was ich da merke ich dass da auch
interesse an meiner person ist aber
eigentlich so im großen und ganzen ist
das jetzt nicht so und das merke ich zum
beispiel daran dass ich fast 500.000
abonnenten auf fast 500.000 schon fast
500.000 abonnenten hab ich schon auf
youtube inhalt 116000 auf instagram
daran merke ich halt schon dass mein
also die leute weil meine videos schauen
und nicht die gehen danach nicht auf
instagram und bei mir folgen weil ich so
super treu bin und das ist mir noch mal
klarer geworden als ich dann den
instagram account von kult mörder
gesehen habe coldmirror ist
für mich die coolste kreativste beste
person im internet
ungelogen und gleichzeitig weiß ich dass
ihr leben glaube ich nicht perfekt ist
sie hat viele schicksalsschläge erfahren
müssen
sie hat auch schon über depressionen
selbstmord gesprochen gesprochen und
instagram account hat ich glaube 50
tausend follower und ihr youtube account
800.000 ungefähr und daran möglichkeit
auch es ist nicht bei jeder person so
dass man irgendwie alles über sie wissen
will
es reicht für mich und für eine kultur
und vielleicht noch für andere dass man
einfach das tun was man liebt kreativ
sein auf youtube das ist das was ich
einfach was mich erfüllt videos machen
neue sachen ausprobieren neue formate
ausprobieren gucken wie sie ankommen
gucken wie es mir gefällt ich habe so
viel neues gelernt in den letzten
monaten zum thema kochen
ich koche mittlerweile so gerne und
kochen ist für mich so eine richtige so
ein abenteuer geworden und ich finde es
cool dass ihr das genauso verehrt wie
ich und das sollte mein ding sein
kreative videos machen denn das ist das
was gewollt wird das ist das womit ich
mein geld verdiene
das ist da es womit wofür wovon ich
leben möchte und ich bin so happy dass
ich mittlerweile sagen kann das ganze
andere das bin ich nicht
das bin ich vielleicht bin ich das bald
vielleicht in einem jahr kriege ich
wieder ein sinneswandel sage ich möchte
jetzt jeden tag ein schönes bild von mir
posten aber jetzt nicht und ich bin so
froh und ich möchte euch ganz ehrlich da
draußen sagen für viele junge frauen
aber auch junge männer überlegt euch ob
ihr das wirklich machen wollt haben
wollt sein wollt ist
macht es euch glücklich fragt euch das
wirklich und dann nicht vielleicht die
app firma paar tage weil ich werde sie
jetzt löschen
und ich gebe euch sprechen update
vielleicht kann ja auch sein dass in
drei wochen so vermisste und denke wow
es war nur ein komischer gedanken den
ich damals hat aber jetzt nicht mehr
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass ich bei
der meinung bleibe das instagram nicht
meins ist ja aber es ich fand das war
jetzt ein thema was ich wirklich
ansprechen wollte was ich wirklich
wichtig fand also nachdem mir das heute
so klar geworden ist habe ich gemerkt
ich muss das auch den leuten da draußen
sagen und es wird jetzt wieder ein video
commerce sehr gut finden werdet was
normal wanne content ist und ziemlich
cool wie schmeckt die werden auch noch
kommen
ich weiß dass ihr immer sehr darauf
wartet das ist mir bewusst
aber da nehme ich mir auch immer die
freiheit ist nicht zu übertreiben
stellt euch mal vor ich mir jetzt immer
nur ex machen das würde mir ja dann
vielleicht auch auf den sack gehen und
das möchte ich vermeiden deswegen gibt
es das in meinem kleinen patienten
tragen ich meine miete zahlen kann es eh
alles super für mich ok habe ich alles
gesagt ich habe denke ich alles gesagt
gibt es elf natur ist on the internet
and en wid ein neues tattoo
ich find's super ist ein vogel und meine
neuen haare
ich weiß es ist der so eller look jetzt
müsste ich auch eigentlich anfang nur
noch zur seite in die seitliche kamera
zu gucken und zu reden das ist so
schlimm wenn youtuber das macht nun
reingucken
ja ich war total inspiriert von diesem
so eller haben wer sie kennt der weiß
was ich meine
die hat jetzt aber mittlerweile auch
schon wieder blonder oder so aber ich
wollte mal führen frühling jetzt eine
neuerung
und ich sage euch das viel lieber auf
youtube als auch instagram auf twitter
werde die mich weiterhin finden
mutterliebe ich aber instagram nein
danke tschüssi copski
[Musik]